you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode du coup de fil
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une
histoire
alors je vous ai bien raconter des
mythes en mai d'anciennes vidéos mais je
vous ai jamais fameux coup de fil en
entier sur un note
et bien c'est sur le point de changer
puisque aujourd'hui on va parler du
mythe arrive en version du mythe de
prométhée
moi je vous parlais de celle de platon
dans protagoras va d'abord l'exposé
ensuite on va essayer d'aller un petit
peu plus loin voilà et pour les versions
ou la trouveront description toujours
tchéquie la description de mes vidéos
endroit il ya très très très très très
très longtemps
les dieux ont créé des espèces mortels
donc les hommes et les animaux et l'ont
fait à base de terre et de feu dressées
par mal parce que avec de la terre et du
feu au mieux c'était très bas l'aise tu
obtiens salle
j'espère qu'on ressemble pas à ça et là
ils ont demandé à deux titans les titans
c'est des êtres divins qui étaient là
avant les dieux de l'olympe et qui sont
hyper géant hyper balèze etc et ces deux
titans ses épis m'étais et prométhée et
l'on demandait de faire le partage des
caractéristiques et des qualités de ces
être mortelle bon vous partager ça bien
ok vous me promettez d'un sérieux
au courage les pubs et et la dose et
puis bété comme ton prénom mais c'est
pas drôle en fait on le dit tito
epiméthée dont le nom veut dire celui
qui réfléchit après coup veut faire le
partage tout seul et promettait accepte
ça sent la merde là ou pas non parce que
le mec qui s'appelle celui qui réfléchit
après coup donc soit ses parents ses
débats tard soit c'est vrai et on lui
confie le partage des qualités d être
mortelle du coup le mec fait son partage
et le fait bien
j'aurai ma donné à certaines espèces la
force à d'autres espèces la vitesse doit
pas même d'espèces parce que sinon ça va
créer un déséquilibre il y aura des
espèces bien avantagé par rapport à
d'autres aux espèces qui n'ont pas
d'armes elles vont pouvoir s'envoler
facilement ou s'engouffrer sous terre
pour se protéger et aussi les trois qui
peuvent se reproduire beaucoup plus
facilement que les prédateurs et puis en
fonction de son les espèces et bavard du
pelage
des écailles etc bref en gros super bien
pensé il reste des élèves des poils et
des palmes maintien jacquet lui mettre
les ailes et les poils ah bah non mais
j'ai déjà mis un bec de canard 4 heures
du mat aller tant pis mec t'es au
courant ne s'est pas du tout passé comme
ça oui
non mais là c'est pas du tout
scientifique ton truc c'est un mythe
c'est une histoire ouais mais tu sais
que celle inverse les eaux
ouais c'est un mythe les gens savent pas
inquiète ou qui précise le quand même
alors je peux quand même faire une
petite précision pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la théorie de
l'évolution des espèces
c'est effectivement l'un vers ce qui
s'est passé 1 pour de vrai c'est à dire
que schématiquement les espèces avait
des caractéristiques et celles qui ont
survécu c'est celle qui avait un
environnement favorable à ces
caractéristiques là mais c'est pas comme
le dit le mythe de prométhée genre
suivant leur environnement on va leur
donner certaines caractéristiques non
c'est l'inversé qui s'est passé mais non
seulement c'est quelque chose que platon
ne savait pas et en plus c'est un mythe
mythe d'arc à la base on sait que c'est
pas très vrai quoi du coup et c'est là
qu'on arrive à la bêtise et puis mettez
dans son partagera l oubli mais humain
voilà où on se retrouve à poil sans
armes sans ailes bref nul vous promettez
quand ils voient ça il n'est pas très
content mais en fait je pense qu'il
restait des qualités là je sais pas trop
chez élise je pense que si je vais
gueule oui et prométhée qui veut dire
celui qui réfléchit avant même s'ils
réfléchissaient vraiment avant il aurait
peut-être pas laisser son frère qui
s'appelle celui qui réfléchit après
voilà prométhée décide de sauver les
hommes et pour ça il va aller voler un
truc qui appartient aux dieux ils
décident de voler la connaissance des
arts et le feu parce que la connaissance
des arts sans le feu c'est quand même
extrêmement limité vu que c'est le feu
qui t'aident à quasiment tout construire
à la base du cou une part en cash est
volé le feu et l'habilité technique
auprès des failles stoos le dieu du feu
et d'athéna la déesse de la sagesse et
des artistes et en gros pour platon ses
épéistes hausse et athéna ensemble qui
sont les divinités de la techno c'est à
dire de l'art et de la technique
j'ai le feu et la connaissance des aff
cool tu peux parler un slip alors
parenthèse je précise que deux sauces et
vénère et que du coup il a décidé de
punir prométhée et pas qu'un peu
puisqu'il la tâche est une montagne dans
le caucase et qu' il ya un aigle qui
vient lui bouffer son foie qui repousse
tous les goûts donc là les amis
commencent à faire des trucs de fou
comme par exemple se construisent des
armes des maisons etc mais ils sont
quand même dominé par les loups les ours
les fautes
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont isolés
à cette époque les villes n'existait pas
et quand les hommes se réunissaient et
se taper dessus
du coup deux sagas de ça et il a peur
que notre race ne survivent pas donc ils
appellent hermès et lui demande de nous
donner la pudeur et la justice pour
qu'on puisse créer des sociétés
maintenant reste à savoir comment ça se
distribuent parce que la ressasser
distribués de manière bien spécifique
en gros il ya les experts et tout le
monde ne maîtrise pas l'art de la guerre
où l'art médical
sauf que là deux cydia hermès croquer
moi je veux que tu en donnes à tout le
monde parce que sinon on pourra pas
faire de ville et pour platon c'est pour
ça que sur des sujets d expertise à tout
le monde n'a pas la légitimité de donner
son avis alors que pour la politique
tout le monde peut s'exprimer patron
vous êtes sur ce t2 bonne idée d'enfiler
à tout le monde
l'ancien michel de la compta qui
concevoir une licence en géopolitique
oui c'est important que tout le monde
puisse parler rien n'est pas obligé de
les égoutter
j'ai eu peur on ne fait pas ça patron il
ya plusieurs points qu'il faut voir et
qui se dégage de ce mythe déjà les
animaux et les hommes et sont nettement
séparés d'anglais en fait ils ont pas le
même traitement
par exemple les animaux ils ont des
caractéristiques et des qualités qui
viennent des films étaient alors que
nous ça vient directement des dieux mon
pote donc nous on a quelque chose de
l'ordre du divin et ça les animaux ne
l'ont pas alors je parle bien de ce que
nous dit ce mythe ce nom parce que je
trouve à venir au fond là à créer
spécisme si je t'ai vu ensuite si on
s'attarde un petit peu sur les
connaissances du débat eh bien on a la
connaissance de la et c'est l'art au
sens grec
c'est à dire la techno donc en gros
c'est pas juste faire des tableaux etc
la rhétorique saana l'ingénérie c'est un
art en fait tout ce qui requiert de la
technique c'est un art je pense que je
ferai une vidéo dessus un jour et
promettez va l'amener avec le feu et si
on se rend compte
le feu s'est quand même l'outil qui va
nous permettre de créer les ont tous
types en gros le feu c'est la raison et
plus largement c'est l'intelligence
après c'est intéressant de voir que le
mythe dégage clairement deux dimensions
et à d'abord la dimension technique
c'est ce que nous donne prométhée c'est
en gros la connaissance de l'art et
l'intelligence et il ya la dimension
morale c'est ce que nous donne deux
vieilles m c'est à dire la pudeur et la
justice d'ailleurs de la même façon
pudeur à eidos en grec c'est plus large
que le sens qu'on a aujourd'hui
parce que sinon c'est chou on tue le
renvoi la justice et surtout la pudeur
j'en ai ras le cul de les voir se
promener à poil
dommage non sky d'eau ces notions qui
regroupe des choses comme l'honneur et
le respect la même façon la justice
c'est plus large là on parle aussi de
coutume et de droit donc le fait qu'il y
ait d'un côté une dimension technique et
de l'autre côté une dimension morale et
que les deux soient bien séparées dans
le mythe et ben c'est bien vu et c'est
totalement vrai parce que c'est des
choses qui sont dissociées
par exemple on fait des découvertes
scientifiques d'abord on se pose des
questions morales ou éthiques après et
c'est aussi marins de voir que le mythe
apprécié des des découvertes
paléontologiques parce qu'on nous dit
dans le mythe que toutes les sociétés
elles ont là la technique la raison et
sait où qu'elle soit finalement en tout
cas si vous voulez avoir d'autres
qualités divines super cool sachez que
les dieux de l'olympe sont chargés de
vous invite à vous abonner à cette
chaîne pour ne rater aucun épisode et
surtout à passer le coup de fil à un ami
parce que les idées les plus fortes
c'est les idées partagées nous
du love et de la piste merci à léo de la
chaîne d'articles oggi quand j'ai écrit
un script je suis qui serait sourd les
infusions que c'est normal de la paix
directes si vous connaissez pas
n'hésitez pas à aller voir sa chaîne
c'est intéressant comme d'habitude on se
retrouve dans deux semaines je vous
laisse me rejoindre sur facebook et
twitter
c'est des plateformes sur lesquelles je
balance des contenus exclusifs
relativement indifférents donc surtout
d'avoir le coup d'y aller et ce match à
315 jours vous savez pour ce continent
quel beau nom